pas
[Musique]
la 11ème édition du relais pour la vie
s'est déroulée ces samedis et dimanches
7 et 8 avril à bras panon
un événement organisé par la ligue
contre le cancer qui rassemble des
équipes de marcheurs et de coureurs qui
se relaient pendant 24 heures le relais
pour la vie c'est une manifestation qui
va permettre de récupérer les fonds
mais surtout pour passer un message très
fort c'est à dire que le cancer ne dort
jamais c'est pour ça que pendant 24
heures les gens vont se relayer ils vont
marcher ou courir à gestes de la vie
un geste de solidarité l'est et la
commune de bras-panon envie aujourd'hui
de dire nous les avec sont toutes celles
et tous ceux qui souffrent dans la vie
et qui aujourd'hui ont besoin d'avoir ce
moment qui n'est que 24 heures mais qui
est un moment
aujourd'hui papa maman en forme se
réunissent pour une seule cause la lutte
contre le cancer
la manifestation a pour but de récolter
des fonds afin d'aider et d'accompagner
les malades en situation financière
précaire
le président du département cyrille
melchior a souhaité participer à cet
élan de solidarité en cohérence avec sa
politique d'accompagnement social au
relais pour la vie poids lourds est
extrêmement important dans le sens où le
département doit accompagner celles et
ceux qui souffrent de cette terrible
maladie qu'est le cancer le cancer
frappe des personnes mais toute la
famille est touchée aussi et nous avons
une politique d'accompagnement social de
ces familles de ces malades et à travers
notre présence et ma présence ici j'ai
voulu montrer notre solidarité envers
les malades envers leur famille et leur
dire que l'espoir doit vive et nous
sommes là pour les accompagner dans
leurs efforts ce ne sont pas moins de
200 équipes qui ont répondu présentes
cette année on est la bonne de 10 de
participation à nos membres de
l'association en distraction bain au
relais pour la vie parce que nous ne
nous sentons tous concernés par la ricoh
le cancer 1
voilà les fonds récoltés l'année
dernière ont permis la prise en charge
de soins de confort du surplus des
prothèses capillaires ou encore dead
ménagères
[Musique]